the man convicted of shooting and
killing senator robert kennedy in 1968
may be one step closer to being released
from prison a two-member california
parole board panel voted friday in favor
of starhan sirhan's request for
parole
some of kennedy's children agree with
the board sergeant sergeant has served
53 years of a life sentence it's now up
to california governor gavin newsom or
whoever succeeds him to uphold or reject
the parole board's decision
sir han sirhan seen here yesterday in
california department of corrections and
rehabilitation photos is now 77 years
old he told the parole board at an
online hearing he had little memory of
the 1968 assassination but he must have
been responsible for bringing the gun
and said i take responsibility for
firing the shots that killed senator
robert kennedy in los angeles we are a
great country in a selfish country and a
compassionate country kennedy is
believed to have been sirhan's target
because he supported israel sirhan was a
palestinian refugee who had fled israeli
rule and moved to southern california as
a child just after midnight on june 5th
1968
kennedy left the podium and walked
through the nearby kitchen the first
shot that rang out that night
hit you
yes
paul schrade a union official was with
him
in and out with a few couple of
fragments left there four bullets hit
the senator one to his head he was
pronounced dead in a los angeles
hospital the next day at 24 years old
sirhan was sentenced to death but three
years later california's death penalty
was abolished his sentence was reduced
to life in prison making him eligible to
seek parole which he did 16 times three
of the senator's children have even
publicly shown support my family had a
lot of tragedies but many american
families don't we interviewed robert
kennedy junior three years ago after he
met with sirhan
it's hard to believe that siren
shot my dad
that leads you to conclude what and my
opinion is really irrelevant what's
important is what the facts say what the
autopsy says with the ballistic evidence
and what the eyewitnesses said paul
schrade believes there was a second
gunman shooting from behind
so you believe the man who shot you
and
four other people
did not shoot
and kill robert f kennedy
he couldn't
he was never in a position to do that
after those first two shots
he tried to shoot robert kennedy with
the first two shots but missed but shot
me first and missed on the second bullet
the los angeles police department was
charged with the investigation and has
disputed all claims of a conspiracy
in a statement yesterday one parole
board commissioner said age is a
consideration of parole and it was part
of the review of sirhan
a couple things stand out michelle only
two kennedys are supporting this we
should say and also this was something
that impacted so many people in the
country and actually your family as as
we know personally yes i'm forever
touched by the story because my father
was a delegate was there that night i
campaigned with him that night and was
the first to get to him as a physician
to treat him and treat two other people
that night etched in his uh memory of
that event of course questions for him
and so many others what if what if that
had not happened and again this is not a
done deal it's up to the governor right
at this point 120 days